cette vidéo est sponsorisé par cooper
plus d'informations en fin de vidéo
la question du smartphone a toujours été
très importante pour moi pour une raison
simple
j'y passe un temps considérable j'ai
passé déjà pas mal de temps quand
j'étais en couple et j'ai fait des
vidéos sur le sujet en donnant des
conseils efficaces quand on les met en
oeuvre
mais le souci c'est que depuis que suis
célibataire
j'ai pas envie de les mettre en oeuvre
ses conseils parce qu'en fait maintenant
mon smartphone c'est mon seul lien avec
les autres je suis tout le temps chez
moi tout seul je fais que bosser et en
fait mon smartphone c'est devenu ma
bulle d'air de sociabilité et de
divertissement et donc en fait en
quelques mois mon smartphone a pris une
place disproportionnée dans ma vie on
parle d'une dizaine d'heures par jour
voilà et c'est à ce moment là je me suis
dit ce serait peut-être pas une mauvaise
idée de tester le dôme faune hold'em
fois ne sais quoi
dob ça veut dire idiot donc d'hommes
phone c'est un téléphone bête en
opposition aux smartphones qui est le
téléphone intelligent alors l'intérêt du
dôme phone c'est qu'il ya pas ou presque
pas d'application ou alors c'est
tellement désagréable de les utiliser
parce que l'interface est nul
l'écran est petit et c'est que vous
allez même pas vouloir yale ça ressemble
vraiment à ça donc vous pouvez quand
même joindre les gens les gens peuvent
vous joindre via appels via sms avec ce
genre de clavier là il ya quelques zappé
par exemple whatsapp une appli de mails
via google maps
voilà ce genre de truc mais tout est
globalement difficile d'accès
contrairement aux smartphones ou là le
but c'est de faciliter le trajet entre
votre volonté consciente ou non et ce
qui se passe sur l'écran de votre
téléphone
l'art nettement si je veux envoyer un
message à un pote avec ce clavier là
c'est que j'en ai vraiment envie aussi
j'ai pris un avocat 90 en hommage à
matrix
mais n'importe quel jeune faune fera la
faire pour l'usagé que j'en ai eu en
tout cas le mieux c'est toujours de
prendre des dom faune qu'on a déjà à la
maison dans des tiroirs je n'ai pas tout
homme faune à la maison dans mes tiroirs
au passage n'hésitez pas à les recycler
c'est pas du tout emplacement mais je
voulais quand même un lien dans la
description dans cet environnement que
le smartphone a envahi le dôme faune
semble être une réponse intéressante et
c'est pour ça que il y a plein de
youtube heures et du tout buzz qui ont
fait des vidéos sur le sujet en
l'essayant pendant une semaine ou un an
voilà donc je me suis dit que voilà j'ai
essayé et j'ai essayé je les fais et
c'est de la merde c'est de la bonne
grosse paire d'as je précise aussi que
j'ai filmé quelques passages pendant mon
expérience j'ai pas revu ses passages
avant de faire cette vidéo
donc vous allez peut-être avoir deux
trames narratives en parallèle voilà mes
choix et c'est intéressant parce que là
peut-être que mon impression sur le coup
n'est pas la même que celle que j'ai un
mois plus tard et je trouvais ça bien de
garder les deux en fait voilà donc là je
peux pas payer ce que je voulais payer
parce que j'ai pas vraiment smartphone
donc vu que c'est plus un numéro qu'ils
envoient mais c'est un truc sur
l'application
je suis coincé en fait mais en tout cas
ce que je retiens aujourd'hui un mois
plus tard c'est que c'était de la merde
et ça m'embête parce que moi je vous
faire une vidéo stylet quoi en mode
transformation tout ça et c'est ben
voilà comme ça m'a changé
mais non j'ai pas vous faire croire que
c'était cool quand j'ai trouvé que
c'était de la merde mais cyrus temps n'a
rien tirer de cette expérience c'est
sûrement la question que vous posez
actuellement et je vais y répondre
ne vous inquiétez pas alors il ya
évidemment tout un pan de réflexion sur
l'objet smartphones et l'extension de
soi que c'est devenu dans ma vidéo je
deviens un cyborg celle où je me plante
un capteur sur le torse pour
expérimenter le fait d'être un cyborg
j'en reparle pour les gens qui n'étaient
pas là pour leur donner envie d'aller à
voir
petites techniques de communication
voilà faire vivre son catalogue la base
dans cette vidéo il y avait déjà cette
réflexion sur qu'est ce qui faisait de
nous des cyborgs
est-ce qu'il ya besoin que l'objet soit
vraiment intégré physiquement à nous
pour parler de cybernétique aujourd'hui
le smartphone il est peut-être pas
physiquement intégré à nous mais
psychiquement
c'est quand même pas mal en tout cas moi
personnellement je suis bien atteint
quoi genre parfois je le sens où je
l'entends vibrer comme ça alors que pas
du tout vous citez vous fait ça non
sérieux attendez vous êtes en train de
me dire que il y à une étude qui a dit
que 89 % des participants de cette étude
là avait ce même problème
c'est fou ça je vous êtes recalés des
études à chaque fois parce que sinon
youtube ne veut pas que je sorte la
vidéo le fait que j'entends mon
téléphone vibre et alors qu il ne vibre
pas ça montre que quand même
psychiquement
le truc il est bien implanté quoi donc
quelque part me priver de mon smartphone
c'est me privais un petit peu d'une
partie de moi et c'est un plus que j'ai
ressenti quoi ça que le fait de ne pas
avoir un objet au bout de ses mains avec
lequel j'étais vraiment connecté au
monde avec un flux d'informations entre
ans qui était assez fou etc
à part ça ça m'a fait du bien genre
c'était fou c'était cool de ne pas
devoir tout le temps avoir ma main sur
ce truc quoi ceci dit j'ai un problème
là qui va m'obliger à repasser sur
smartphone
pendant je pense une heure parce qu'en
fait pour rejoindre mes applis bancaire
ou faire quelques paiement il me demande
à chaque fois de valider avec mon ap qui
est sur mon téléphone est attendu combat
je trouve à ces événements qui sont
importants c'est de l'argent qu'il faut
que j'envoie des gens quoi donc c'est
parti on va rallumer le smartphone par
marange à l'est en fait transférer la
carte sim mais je crois que j'ai même
pas besoin en fait on va terrasser fait
plaisir ce que je avant quand je l'avais
dans les mains vraiment enfin là je sens
que le fait de l'avoir dans les mains
j'ai déjà une autre relation à à 7 août
il mais je sens aussi que ça peut
revenir très très vite genre en quelques
années tu penses ok ça me fait un truc
chelou ça me fait c'est la peur en fait
que je ressens ça me fait peur quoi
genre là l'écran et sa fille chérie tout
et je ressens de la peur est aussi des
modifications genre en lisant je me
rends compte que je me demande bas les
steaks totalement de certaines
notifications ces jolis seins c'est joli
toutes les applis et où s'écoule encore
ça me saoule
ça me saoule parce que sky hyper bien
quoi tel que je me verrais pas je pense
être sûr du dôme faune long terme quoi
c'est cette vidéo elle est un peu triste
un joli direct dans cette vidéo les
tristes je suis pas du tout fier de tout
ce que je raconte j'ai honte mais je
pense comme beaucoup de gens qui ont des
addictions ou des dérives
comportementales sur des éléments de
leur environnement je suis pas surpris
d'avoir honte
en fait lâcher d'autant plus content je
vous la raconte à des milliers de gens à
mais bon j'ai fait pire
j'ai partagé pierre jean temps de
réécrire la au clavier c'est hyper
bizarre la sensation c'est encore une
fois c'est de la peur quoi c'est ça me
renvoie à quelque chose
que j'ai beaucoup beaucoup fait et que
j'ai pas toujours fait dans des
conditions agréables en fait j'ai peur
parce que je me vois redevenir ce que je
n'aime pas c'est une tristesse c'est une
violence un peu en tout cas ce bien être
physique c'était voilà c'était un peu
libérateur mais ça c'était juste
physique
ok psychiquement c'est pas du tout ça
qui s'est passé là où cette expérience
elle est nulle pour un mec comme moi
c'est que je sors très peu de chez moi
et en ce moment encore moins donc en
fait tous les outils que j'utilise et
sur le smartphone bah je les ai utilisés
sur l'ordi quoi j'avais instagram sur
l'ordi j'avais twitter sur l'ordi la
musique sur l'ordi j'avais même des
applis de rencontres sur l'ordi si on
peut d'ailleurs du coup vu que j'étais
avec le clavier de l'ordi parfois je
faisais des approches beaucoup trop
longue qui tenait vraiment très peu de
résultats
donc en fait je sentais le dôme phone
seulement quand je sortais de chez moi
quoi
et comme je vous disais c'est pas
souvent je suis dans une caverne nous y
voilà c'est ma caverne
c'est ma caverne je suis là voilà tous
les soirs comme ça en train de réfléchir
prochain sujet de vidéos
comment la société est en train de
dériver dans un état que je ne saurais
décrire et pourtant m'appelle à prendre
parole et à m'exprimer
voilà voilà donc je sors pas parce que
ça prend beaucoup de temps de faire ça
j'aime me faire à manger je vais me
faire un risotto à la truffe
voilà
c'est de la balle as c'est vraiment trop
beau crois que c'est aussi pour ça que
je filme là maintenant ça faisait chez
le manger seul en fait je pense donc là
c'est un petit peu comme si on mange
ensemble parce que j'ai pas vous mentir
l'un des trucs que je ressens plus là au
bout de cinq jours c'est la solitude en
fait c'est genre je me souviens les deux
trois premiers jours j'appelais des
potes juste pour leur dire ouais non
mais j'ai rien à dire en fait je veux
juste parler à quelqu'un quoi parce
qu'avant j'étais tout le temps là est
tout à fait là le moindre texto c'est
compliqué c'est chiant santé neuf et
tout donc si je refais rappelé gérer à
plus de messages vocaux il ya plus de
joie plus qui font j'ai pu leur story je
vois rien en fait
et puis très vite je me suis dit non
mais en fait c'est pas ça le défi là
c'est papa de réseaux sociaux c'est pas
de smartphone parce que pas de réseaux
sociaux je les fait et c'était de la
malle c'était trop bien là c'est un mois
sans smartphone donc ce qui se passe sur
l'ordi on s'en fout et du coup mon ordi
ne me quittait pas quoi ils me suivaient
à chaque instant de la journée et de là
il ya deux réflexions
la première est concerne le vrai apport
de ce challenge pour moi et c'est la
prise de conscience me rendre compte
spécifiquement de ce à quoi je suis
addict
parce qu'en fait de prier avec le
smartphone c'est que tout est mélangé
dans même objet
là je trouve du coup c'est un peu
différent et j'ai vu que clairement mon
problème c'est instagram
c'est pas les fid des gens on y voir
leur story et ses danses et ses la
messagerie instagram
c'est discuté avec des gens toute la
journée non stop les potes les machins
on s'envoie des vocaux tout ça toute la
journée c'est pas possible
et en même temps j'adore j'adore c'est
mon seul lien avec l'extérieur mais
c'est pas possible
mais j'adore non
qu'est ce qui se passe là c'est quoi
cette improvisation celle des rigolos
mais au moins quand j'étais sur l'ordi
je m'en rendais compte parce que c'est
un environnement différent c'est full
screen
je dois ouvrir un navigateur allez sur
instagram
voilà c'est pas la même chose que juste
une nappe tu cliques et puis en plus
c'est la mémoire musculaire avec juste
un geste paf tu rentres dedans
là j'étais beaucoup plus conscients en
fait du temps que je passais sur chaque
appli ou sur chaque site en plus souvent
j'ai un peu manqué un truc que je
faisais parce que j'étais sur l'ordi
alors que d'habitude je suis sur l'ordi
et en parallèle je fais sur un stade
donc à pas d'interruption là je suis
obligée d'interrompre ce que je fais
après c'est peut-être aussi parce que
pour moi alors 10 un environnement de
taff et donc je plus conscients de
commenge dépenses montant voilà ça c'est
possible aussi la seconde réflexion elle
concerne le smartphone et l'espace c'est
quoi la différence majeure entre le
smartphone et l'ordinateur avec le
smartphone en fait ma conversation où
mon article où ma vidéo ça peut me
suivre partout et quand je dis partout
ces mêmes chez moi un typiquement je
peux aller aux toilettes par exemple et
swype est sûre tings ou alors au monde
me brosser les dents je peux scrollé sur
twitter et du coup on perd trop de temps
du coup je me brosse les dents plus tard
et en fait du coup après me brosser les
dents je suis fatigué j'ai la flemme de
mettre de la crème hydratante classique
classique
du coup je me suis dit si au lieu
d'interdire l'outil je lui interdisait
certains espaces c'est ce que j'ai fait
depuis le début de mon emménagement dans
cet appartement
j'ai suivi un conseil que j'avais donnée
dans une de mes précédentes vidéos qui
était pas de smartphone dans la chambre
et donc dans ma chambre je n'ai jamais
utilisé le smartphone depuis depuis que
j'ai 7 appartements quoi il n'est jamais
rentré dans la chambre je les fais une
fois parce que j'avais totalement ap
une fois au début et le fait de faire ça
ça a été incroyable parce qu'en fait
avant je pourrais passer des heures dans
le lit à scrollé genre vous le vous
connaissez le chemin classique
je vais quand même le dire pour que l'on
soit tous d'accord et convives tous la
même chose
le chemin classique instagram ok il ya
plus rien sur instagram twitter ok y'a
plus rien sur twitter je regardais mail
pourquoi pas ok y'a plus rien dans les
mails je retourne sur instagram quand
même ok il ya peut-être un nouveau truc
sur instagram ok je les vues du coup on
ressent sur twitter parfois ya facebook
qui entre dans la course
bref vous voyez très bien ce circuit
alors c'est là que moi que j'ai un
boomer parce que j'ai même pas parler de
tik tok est un chat je vous remet la
vidéo
le truc où tu vas d'appli en appli à la
recherche d'un petit truc nouveau
je suis tellement content de ne plus
vivre ça voilà depuis que je n'ai pas
mon smartphone dans ma chambre
le réveil sonne je me lève je sors du
lit
c'est incroyable ça incroyable du coup
je peux séparé mon appartement en zone
où le smartphone est interdit et 11
zones où le smartphone est autorisée
parfois j'ai commencé à interdire le
smartphone dans la salle de bain en
genre des gérants des 1 salle de bain si
j'avais le smartphone je le pose est
très efficace
voilà je pense que ça c'est un truc que
je veux mettre en place c'est peut-être
ridicule d'en arriver là voilà
jugez-moi jugé - qui se voulait que je
vous dise en tout cas voilà je préfère
ça que de rester sur un homme faune
mais le souci du dôme phone c'est qui
réglait pas le problème il s'est juste
transposer ça sur l'ordi tout en
enlevant ma vie hyper compliqué quoi dès
que je sortais c'était quand même
c'était même rôle ou quand je sortais
par exemple pour certains rendez vous je
devais prendre un taxi
avant j'utilisais mon appli de vtc voilà
là on appelle on appelle la compagnie
taxi
on donne son adresse on sait pas quand
est-ce que le taxi il arrive enfin
voilà c'est le pire exemple voilà c'est
c'est l'exemple le plus bobo parisien
que j'avais en stock
en revanche c'est vrai que quand je me
promenais j'avais pas les yeux rivés sur
mon téléphone et des caves est un
moindre ennui
bah je pouvais pas aller sur mon
téléphone voilà sur ce que en plus ils
ont changé snake le jeu du serpent
je le dis pour les plus jeunes qui
connaissent peut être pas ce n'est qu
ils ont changé c'est devenu nul donc il
y avait même pas ça mais ça pour le coup
bas je pouvais déjà le faire en fait
avec ma watch génois tx cellular ce qui
fait qu'elle peut fonctionner sans le
téléphone est donc parfois je sors avec
juste ma montre comme ça si on contacte
si on a besoin de me joindre
on peut le faire j'ai ma musique et
voilà la musique parlant de la musique
et j'ai vécu un mois sans musique je
sortais sans musique
je me baladais genre soleil et tout
machin c'était le début des beaux jours
sans musique donc un peu triste tout à
l'heure je suis sorti je n'ai pas pris
avec moi en ville en fait c'est même
plus que ça je suis allé faire les
courses aux armements je me dis mince ou
dépendantes et les fans et empêche aussi
mais pourquoi je le prendrais en fait on
risque de m'appeler est ce que vraiment
il ya une urgence aussi importante que
qui peut pas attendre juste un quart
d'heure le temps que je revienne des
courses ou 20 minutes le temps que je
mène des courses non je pense pas donc
en fait je me suis rendu compte que à
chaque fois je le prenais mon smartphone
mais avec cette excuse de l'urgence
ouais mais c'est quelqu'un besoin de me
contacter et en fait quand il ne reste
plus que ça c'est à dire que la raison
de le prendre c'est qu'on me contacter
je le prends pas
donc ça montre que c'est vraiment qu'une
excuse en fait quand je prends mon
smartphone c'est pas du tout pour pas
rater un appel important c est pour est
toujours connecté à voir les notifs
pouvoir répondre à des messages qui sont
pas du tout important pouvoir continuer
à regarder twitter continuer à avoir une
certaine information ne surtout pas
s'ennuyer etc etc et même au delà de
rendre ma vie plus compliquée il me
privais aussi de pas mal de contenu qui
ne sont disponibles que sur smartphone
on applique de sport par exemple mon
appli de finances pour suivre mes
comptes ou bien tout simplement le
sponsor de cette vidéo
cooper alors je précise que je leur ai
demandé de sponsoriser cette vidéo
seulement une fois que j'avais fait mon
expérience que j'en avais tiré les
leçons et que je savais à peu près ce
que je voulais dire c'est très important
pour moi de vous préciser parce que
sinon j'aurais l'impression que ça
change ce contenu alors que ce n'est pas
le cas cooper cenap qui vous permet de
retrouver des résumés de bouquins de
podcasts ou même de documentaires alors
pour les bouquins c'est des résumés de
bouquins nom de fictionné genre sapiens
de harare a été bizarre de résumer par
exemple harry potter bat ans il ya trois
grandes thématiques culture générale
développement perso et développement
prosky écoulé cooper c'est que les
résumés de bouquins vous pouvez aussi
les écouter mois à une certaine époque
je faisais du sport ça arrivait à un
moment oui oui à quoi je faisais du
sport
j'écoutais ça et donc du coup voilà
c'était beaucoup plus agréable de faire
mon sport avec ça en fait quand j'écoute
de la musique je trouve ça trop
répétitif
donc ce qui marche bien avec moi c'est
soit les podcasts soit les résumés de
bouquins donc pour ça c'est parfait
alors en temps normal ces 7 99 par mois
ou 6 67 avec l'abonnement à l'année mais
que le lien de journée une description
vous pouvez voir cooper premium pendant
un mois gratos je vous en ai déjà parlé
sur cette chaîne c'était sur ma vidéo
sur le développement personnel et j'ai
eu plein de retours de votre part qui
avait utilisé cooper et qui ont kiffé
donc c'est trop cool donc je les
remercie j'espère aussi que vous allez
découvrir plein de trucs que vous serez
pas aller forcément creusé en temps
normal par exemple chez capa raison de
la thématique éducation élever des
enfants etc
bon c'est pas du tout
un sujet d'actualité en ce qui me
concerne mais vu que c'est des résumés
de bouquins etc
c'est plus facile je trouve de
s'intéresser à un truc et d'être curieux
et de lire quelques trucs que je pas
d'aller acheter les bouquins les en
entier savoir quelle partie du bouquin
est intéressante pour ce qu'on recherche
etc etc
donc voilà si vous êtes aussi curieux
que moi et je sais que c'est le cas ça
vous plaira sûrement
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
j'espère qu'elle vous a pas trop déçu
non plus parce que peut-être que vous
étiez comme moi peut-être que vous étiez
en mode on va tous se mettre aux dom
faune et ça va être de la balle en tout
cas moi ça me convient pas je préfère
largement par exemple bannir les réseaux
sociaux etc ont aussi mal à garder le
smartphone plutôt que passer aux dom
phone après il ya des alternatives qui
sont en train d'être mise en place d
light faune ça reste des dom phone mais
ils sont allégées auxerre qui a plein
d'ap qui sont pas disponibles dessus
pourquoi pas mais donc ça veut dire quoi
sert quant à son smartphone et sont
l'iphone je sais pas je sais pas quoi en
penser
là ce jour je suis plus dans le comment
faire pour encadrer le smartphone pour
continuer à pouvoir l'utiliser mais que
son utilisation ne pollue pas la vie et
ne me ne me rendra pas plus malheureux
que je ne suis et je pense que c'est
possible et je continuerai à vous en
parler sur cette chaîne parce que je
pense que c'est vraiment un sujet qui
est extrêmement important pour nous tous
en fait je pense que je suis loin d'être
le seul à avoir un souci avec son
téléphone d'ailleurs on est encore plus
ensemble si vous venez me voir sur
tweets le mardi à 22h et souvent
mercredi soir j'ai encore du mal à
m'engager sur mercredi soir parce que
des fois je suis crevée mercredi soir
parce que c'est le jour où chante ma
vidéo mais j'essaie j'essaye au max
suivez moi aussi sur instagram
ah oui ça j'en ai pas parlé mais sur
instagram du coup j'ai pas pu faire de
story pendant un mois
c'était fou les retours que vous m'avez
fait c'était fou quand je suis revenu
la vague d'amour que je me suis pris
c'était fou vous avez été incroyable et
par rapport aux incroyables je remercie
aussi d'ailleurs mon agente qui me
permet de continuer à faire des story
notamment des story sponsorisés parce
que je lui envoyais la story en vidéo
que je filmais que mon ipad et que l
upload est
parce que j'avais fils-aimé compte
instagram quoi voilà c'était c'était
cocasse merci beaucoup à elle d'avoir
assuré pendant ce temps là cet art trop
est beaucoup trop longue
je vous embrasse très fort de plaisir de
vous parler comme ça à d'ailleurs je
fais rien n'est fait que je vais faire
une faq avant l'été parce que pendant
l'été je fais une petite pause et donc
avant la pause je fais un petit effet qu
voilà je vais l'annoncer sur instagram
sur twitter voilà c'est là que je
prendrais vos questions love peace ciao